bouger c'est affolant
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur de nous
avoir accordé cet entretien merci à vous
de votre fidélité c'est la fin de la
grande interview rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu tout
l'univers uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
à la lune un troisième samedi de
mobilisation contre les lois jugées
liberticides sous très haute sécurité à
paris en province à quelques tensions
dans le cortège parti de chaque l'est en
direction de la place de la république
dans la capitale vit dans 119
interpellations selon la préfecture de
police de paris
et puis on a défilé à lille marseille
toulouse et lyon où quelques heurts ont
éclaté champ
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également l'agencé
américaine des médicaments a autorisé
hier fois en urgence l'utilisation du
vaccin father et bien tech
la campagne débutera demain une annonce
qui intervient alors que le pays
enregistrait un nouveau record de
contamination près de 235 mille cas
positifs aux copies de 19 ans 24 heures
et puis l'accord de paris sur le climat
fête ses 5 ans un traité international
visant à réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et l'heure est au bilan
quelles sont les actions climatiques
menées par les pays qui ont ratifié
l'accord éléments de réponse dans ce
journal
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france un troisième
samedi de mobilisation dans toute la
france contre la loi sécurité globale le
bilan 119 interpellations dans la
capitale selon le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
plusieurs appels ont été lancés pour une
mobilisation à paris avec un départ de
châtelet et une arrivée place de la
république
la manifestation parisienne qui s'est
terminée il ya plus d'une heure et vous
voyez sur ces images donc à ce face à
face plutôt joyeux entre des
manifestants des jeunes et les forces de
l'ordre qui avaient enlevé leur casque
une journée de mobilisation également en
région plusieurs défilés ont eu lieu à
toulouse ou encore à lille la police a
dû disperser les manifestants fin de
rassemblement et puis à lyon près de
2000 manifestants ont défilé selon la
préfecture un cordage émaillée par des
jets de projectiles contre les forces de
l'ordre la police a répliqué
voyez par des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
on va faire le point sur cette journée
de mobilisation de retour dans la
capitale à paris avec notre reporter à
thomas bonnin chien nouvelle journée de
mobilisation ce samedi dans la capitale
contre la proposition de loi sécurité
globale plusieurs milliers de
manifestants ont répondu à cet appel
manifestation qui est partie de la place
du châtelet à paris en direction de la
place de la république
est ce que l'on a pu constater tout de
suite c'est l'important dispositif de
sécurité qui avaient été déployées avec
des canons à eau des crs des gendarmes
mobiles ainsi que des membres de la
brave la brigade de répression des
actions violentes qui ont été déployées
en nombre et dès le début de l'après
midi le ministre de l'intérieur se
féliciter d'avoir pu compter 24
interpellations de manifestants qui
étaient devenus avec des objets tels que
des outils ou des marteaux et puis tout
au long de cette manifestation les
forces de l'ordre très présentes en
nombre ont procédé à un certain nombre
d'interpellations en plein milieu de
cette manifestation en effectuant des
charges au sein de ce cortège c'est le
cas notamment de la brave et des crs qui
ont interpellé comme cela plusieurs
manifestants pendant la manifestation
et puis le cortège est arrivé sur la
place de la république est là aussi la
dispersion s'est effectué assez
rapidement parce que la présence des
forces de l'ordre était véritablement
très importante avec encore une fois des
canons à eau qui ont été utilisés
pour disperser la foule cela a
fonctionné puisque en une heure à peine
les manifestants ont quitté cette place
de la république il ya eu encore ensuite
quelques petits groupes de quelques
dizaines de manifestants qui ont tenté
de continuer à battre le pavé mais ils
ont été empêchés par les crs qui ont
utilisé du gaz lacrymogène voilà pour
cette journée de mobilisation ou
vraisemblablement les consignes de la
part de la préfecture de police de paris
était d'éviter toute violence dans la
capitale
on va continuer de parler de cette
journée de mobilisation avec nos invités
dieynaba diop adjointe au maire des
mureaux porte-parole du parti socialiste
et sébastien huyghe député l ère du nord
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord le bilan
que vous faites de cette journée de
mobilisation à paris mais aussi dans
toute la france dans plusieurs villes de
province où il ya eu aussi là on a vu
des heures dieynaba à diop
quand même manifestement la mobilisation
ne dit pas je pense que cela traduit
aussi une certaine inquiétude concernant
cette fois sécurité globale je pense que
les principales notamment celles nous
faisons quelques journalistes avaient
appelé à manifester à paris et jeux et
je salue leur sens des responsabilités
parce que les dernières avaient eu des
conséquences assez mais phase avec cette
intrusion de 400 à 500 casseurs je crois
que c'est difficile de pouvoir discuter
de ces mobilisations parce que les gens
petit à petit se disent que par
responsabilité des ventes plus dans la
rue il faut absolument un débouché
politique aux différentes revendications
et c'est ce que nous attendons du
gouvernement qui est manifestement
n'entend pas et continue à s'entêter sur
cette fois sécurité globale c'est bâtir
young votre sentiment à l'issue de cette
journée
on a un petit souci de liaison avec vous
sébastien que je sais pas si vous nous
entendez députés à l'ère du nord oui
nous en temps voilà je vous demande est
votre sentiment à l'issue d'un soir
sébastien gauche de demain je vous
demander votre sentiment à l'issue de
cette journée de mobilisation
contrôlez loi jugée liberticide ça
allait bien au delà de la mobilisation
contre la loi de sécurité globale moi je
voudrais avoir d'abord une pensée pour
les commerçants qui étais tu heureux
trajet des différents défilés dans toute
la france il sort d'une période très
compliquée avec le confinement ils ont
pu enfin découvrir et on est à une
douzaine de jours de de noël et c'est
très important pour eux de pouvoir être
ouvert et de pouvoir essayer de le
rattraper le chiffre perdu le temps
perdu et pour certains ils sont au bord
de la nive de la suite s'il n'avait
absolument pas besoin d'avoir de telles
manifestations qui leur empêche
d'accueillir convenablement leurs
clients beaucoup ont dû fermer leurs
rideaux et vous savez que un samedi
comme ça juste avant noël c'est
catastrophique pour quant à cette
mobilisation
moi je considère que cette loi sécurité
globale est nécessaire
on connaît la situation dans laquelle
est notre pays en terme de deux
difficultés par rapport à la délinquance
en termes de terrorise et donc il y
avait besoin de permettre je rappelle t
une police municipale
enfin à paris qu' on puisse donner aux
polices municipales des pouvoirs plus
importants de d'utiliser du matériel de
dernière génération je pense notamment
aux drones est donc cette loi permet un
certain nombre de choses alors il ya eu
des maladresses de la part du
gouvernement notamment sur ce fameux
article 24 ou
malgré ce que nous opposition avons pu
dire au gouvernement
ils ont voulu modifier la loi de 1881
relatif à la liberté de la presse
vous savez la politique est faite de
symboles et vouloir modifier la loi qui
permet la liberté de la presse était une
erreur fondamentale on pouvait protéger
les policiers en mettant des infractions
dans le code pénal mais il sans modifier
cette fameuse loi sur la liberté de la
presse qui est essentiel dans notre pays
il fallait pas s'attaquer à ce totem
simplement on pouvait protéger nos
policiers en insérant dans le code pénal
donc de nouvelles infractions et celui
de la mise en danger de la vie de nos
policiers et notamment de donner leur
identité
le lieu où ils habitent comme
aujourd'hui malheureusement ça arrive
trop souvent sur les réseaux sociaux
avec des conséquences majeures comme
certains policiers qui ont été attaqués
dont les familles ont été attaqués
certains ont été même
donc même été tuées donc cette loi ait
été indispensable malheur
malheureusement à cause de la maladresse
du gouvernement on est dans cette
situation qu'elle ait refusé par
beaucoup alors l'article 24 à doit être
doit être revue à la demande donc du
gouvernement qui sort un rétropédalage
dieynaba diop c'est la loi sécurité
globale c'est une loi indispensable
selon vous non elle n'est pas
indispensable et qui comme l'a rappelé
monsieur le gros problème la raison pour
laquelle ça mis le feu aux poudres
notamment chez les gens là disent que
c'est que on pige à la liberté est la
loi qui gagne et gamme is en place et
qui qui toute la liberté de la presse
donc ce n'est pas anodin et puis je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu des
renforcements suite aux différentes les
différents problèmes auxquels on a été
confrontés notamment dans les attentats
de 2004 et un certain nombre de
personnages
art qui est présent aujourd'hui vous
avez déjà des lois qui existent protéger
vos forces de l'ordre et le problème que
l'on a aujourd'hui c'est pas le problème
de la loi c'est l'application de la loi
et puis il ya aussi les démantèlements
des renseignements généraux sous nicolas
sarkozy aussi qu'il ya qui a fait perdre
un temps infini sur 7 sur 7 sur cette
question il faut renforcer les moyens
qui sont mis à disposition de nos forces
de l'ordre et aussi permettre une
meilleure comment dirais-je un meilleur
dialogue interservices pour pouvoir
justement interférer je vous rappelle
que dans que dans le drame de notre de
mon collègue de sa mère pattie à
conflans sainte honorine
il y avait eu des signalements sur la
plateforme pharos mais par manque de
moyens et de réactivité on n'a pas été
en capacité de traiter les signalements
donc ce n'est pas un problème de loi ici
parce que là c'est plus un effet de
communication contre chance mais ça a un
effet de moyens pour pouvoir doter une
force de l'ordre de moyens nécessaires
notamment comme vous le disiez monsieur
de moyens beaucoup plus moderne de
caméras qui soit capable de filmer avec
une autonomie suffisante
un exemple de caméras piétons et cetera
mais aujourd'hui c'est la sécurité
globale
elle ne règle pas les problèmes qui sont
visés et donc c'est pour ça que il y à
une telle opposition à cette loi
les gens ne sont ne sont pas dans la rue
par guy d'acteur c'est vraiment pas
l'objectif n'est pas d'aller casser les
pieds une première dont on sait à quel
point ils ont souffert ces derniers
c'est pas seulement ces dernières
semaines de confinement s'est depuis les
manifestations de gilet jaune
on a des intrusions de casseurs il ya un
problème de stratégie de maintien l'orne
il faut aussi dire les choses quand on
arrive à avoir 400 500 black block qui
en titre quasiment systématiquement les
manifestations de nos concitoyens qui
doivent garder la liberté de manifester
il ya un problème de pondre ont laissé
répondre vous répondre sébastien huyghe
je crois que vous voulez réagir et je
précise qu'à eu 119 interpellation
aujourd'hui même 147 me semblait-il mais
je peux pas laisser ma dame diop dit
tout et n'importe quoi sur nicolas
sarkozy
les services de renseignement étaient au
contraire renforcé il y avait jusqu'à
lors plusieurs services et on vous
voyait que la communication entre les
services ne fonctionnait pas bien et
d'ailleurs madame diop je viens de dire
qu' il faut favoriser le dialogue entre
les différents services et ce qui a été
fait au niveau des services de
renseignement s'était regroupé
l'ensemble des services pour que
justement tout le monde travaille
ensemble et pas chacun dans son coin
avec eux des renseignements qui auraient
pu échapper aux uns et aux autres donc
que c'est bien renforcement alors je
sais que c'est l'antienne du parti
socialiste de google à taper sans arrêt
sur nicolas sarkozy mais les choses ont
été renforcées et je rappelle que la
délinquance a diminué ce nicolas sarkozy
alors qu'elles avaient augmenté sous
françois hollande mais ceci dit cette
loi sur la sécurité globale porte mal
son nom parce qu'elle n'est pas du tout
sur la sécurité globale par exemple mans
que tout le volet de lutte contre le
terrorisme
elle permet cependant de faire un
certain nombre d'avancées notamment gelé
dit tout à l'heure sur le fait que les
polices municipales qui sont les polices
véritablement de proximité et bien
puisse avoir plus de pouvoir lorsqu'ils
sont sur les lieux et qu'il se passe
quelque chose
on a absolument besoin d'avoir un cadre
légal pour l'utilisation de tous les
moyens modernes parce que aujourd'hui
certains sont utilisés à certains
endroits d'autres prénoms et âges
puisque justement une loi aussi un
projet de loi anciennement appelée
séparatisme aussi et ça faisait aussi
l'objet de beaucoup de polémiques c'est
aussi l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
les manifestants aujourd'hui
se sont mobilisés dans les rues
parisiennes et dans toute la france
aussi pas seulement pour la loi sécurité
globale non mais nous avons vécu un
certain nombre d'actes terroristes et
nous sommes toujours sous la menace
terroriste dans notre pays il est
indispensable de pouvoir réagir et de
pouvoir faire en sorte de lutter contre
cet islamisme radical qui s'étend dans
notre pays et qui prend j'allais dire
quasiment le pouvoir dans un certain
nombre de nos quartiers
donc il y as besoin de réagir il ya
besoin pour la france de faire en sorte
de pouvoir avoir une réponse qui puisse
être mise en place par rapport à la
situation dans laquelle on est on vient
d'évoquer samuel pâtit il y a à nice les
personnes qui ont été attaqués et tués
dans une église
il est indispensable pour le de lutter
contre ce chronique communautarisme et
ceux qui ont dévoyé l'une des religions
de france avec cet islamiste radical
dina bell justement cours pour éviter
les amalgames qu'on peut qu on pourrait
regretter il faut s'attaquer à ceux qui
ont dévoyé
cette religion qui est normalement une
religion de paix mondiale abadie rap
pour conclure pourquoi je dirais juste
que ce départ des projets doit on arrive
à lutter contre justement l'islam
radical ou encore éradiquer risation
adam d'un certain dans certains
quartiers ce qu'il faut c'est plus de
service public
c'est effectivement delà de la police de
proximité mais ils ne sont pas je pense
mélanger les missions de la police
nationale et celle de la police
municipale
si vous voulez justement lutter contre
ces foyers de radicalisation il faut du
service public
il faut des moyens il faut il faut des
gens pour pouvoir justement aller
chercher discuter avec ces personnes là
et qui sanctionnait sans faillir
lorsqu'il ya des attentes à nos libertés
et à notre république puisque
effectivement ce qui nous tient ensemble
c'est la laïcité et il ne faut pas
qu'une petite poignée de personnes qui
sont tout sauf des défenseurs de cette
religion qui est une religion de paix
qu'on voulait aller raté mais qui sont
seulement des terroristes qui prennent
pour prétexte la religion merci beaucoup
à vous d'eux dieynaba diop adjointe au
maire à des mureaux porte-parole du
parti socialiste merci également à vous
à sébastien lieu gab députés l ère du
nord donc plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont donc décidé dans toute la
france aujourd'hui on écoute et ses
réactions recueillies à paris dans le
cortège aujourd'hui le pouvoir avec
cette nouvelle doit sécurité globale et
la loi séparatisme également prépare
finalement une contre-offensive contre
tout mouvement social et toute
expression populaire en cherchant à
justement diminuer les possibilités de
cette expression populaire et donc
forcément aujourd'hui c'est un rendez
vous immanquable pour nous puisque
on est là pour défendre nos droits et
surtout les droits de s'exprimer dans le
droit français c'est la liberté qui est
la norme est l'exception
j'ai la restriction de liberté là on est
en train de changer de paradigme en
pause en partant du principe que tout le
monde est potentiellement suspect que
toute personne qui viendrait avoir des
idées qui remettrait en cause ce système
actuel serait du coup suspecte et
mériterait d'être contrôlé à minima ça
c'est déjà pas acceptable dans ce qu'on
appelle un état de droit découpé en ce
moment on a toutes nos libertés qui sont
fracassés
donc visiblement rien ne change la
mobilisation est de moins en moins forte
mais bon il faut pas se décourager
il faut persévérer jusqu'à ce que nos
libertés sont respectées
voilà tout simplement à toulouse et à
lille et manifestations se sont
déroulées dans le calme dans d'autres
villes il ya eu des tensions en retour
en images sur cette journée de
mobilisation
regardez
et
m
[Musique]
max
chacun de nourrissage vérité et justice
avec matip
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
et un tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'actualité également aux états
unis ce sera le vaccin issu du
partenariat finder est bien de teck qui
sera administré dès demain l'agencé
américaine des médicaments a autorisé
son auto son utilisation hier soir 3
millions de doses donc sont en train
d'être expédiés en priorité aux hôpitaux
et aux pharmacies et dans quelques
villes illustration à chicago nous nous
sommes organisés pour être en mesure de
procéder à une vaccination de masse
une fois que nous aurons reçu le vaccin
et que nous serons prêts à commencer
donc juste derrière moi vous voyez que
chacune de ces zones offrent à la fois
l'intimité et la flexibilité nécessaire
pour enchaîner ce congélateur ultra bas
on ne peut l'ouvrir plus de deux minutes
sinon il est hors service
il faut donc être très précis dans nos
mouvements et une fois le médicament
sortie nous devons le mettre au
réfrigérateur dans un délai de dix
minutes pour qu'il n'y ait pas un
dégivrage ultra rapide
si la décongélation est trop rapide la
stabilité n'est que de deux heures si
elle est lente
la stabilité est de cinq jours c'est une
petite lueur d'espoir c'est très
surréaliste je suis impatiente mais avec
prudence je pense que nous avons passé
tellement de temps à être triste pour
tant de choses c'est presque étrange de
se sentir heureux pour quelque chose en
rapport avec cette pandémie
et depuis l'annoncé de l'efficacité du
vaccin faveur biotech ou encore celui de
modern à donald trump n'avait qu'une
hâte que l' agence américaine donne son
feu vert et il l'a fait savoir regarder
un sujet de solenn gaudin un miracle
c'est ainsi que donald trump te
qualifies le vaccin de l'alliance finder
et biotech autorisé ce vendredi par la
fda l'agencé américaine du médicament
j'ai de très bonnes nouvelles
aujourd'hui notre nation a réalisé un
miracle médical
nous avons fourni un vaccin sûr et
efficace en seulement neuf mois
c'est l'une des plus grandes
réalisations scientifiques de l'histoire
cela va sauver des millions de vies et
mettra bientôt fin à la pandémie une
fois pour toutes
un retournement de situation en un mois
le 10 novembre dernier le président
américain criait au complot politique
alors que le duo pharmaceutique venait
d'annoncer l'efficacité à 90% de son
vaccin
seulement une semaine après le scrutin
présidentiel américain duquel joe biden
son adversaire démocrate sortait gagnant
comme je le dis depuis longtemps files
heures et les autres l'annoncerai un
vaccin qu'après l'élection parce qu'il
n'avait pas le courage de le faire avant
de même la fda aurait dû l'annoncer
plutôt non pas à des fins politiques
mais pour sauver débit d accusation
rejetée par la direction de pfizer
cinq jours plus tard un autre
laboratoire américain met au point un
vaccin efficace
le géant moderna devient alors le
nouveau cheval de bataille de trump un
autre vaccin vient juste d'être annoncé
cette fois il est 2 moderna et est
efficace à 95% que tous les grands
historiens veulent bien se rappeler que
ces grandes découvertes qui mettront fin
à l'épidémie chinoises se sont faites
sous ma présidence
donald trump s'insère dans la course à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
ces vaccins et talonne l'agencé
américaine du médicament
grâce à mes efforts pour la pousser
l'afd a aussi riche que bureaucratique à
économiser 5 ans pour l'approbation de
nombreux grands nouveau vaccin
elle reste une tortue lente grosse et
biais y mettez les fichus vaccin
circulation maintenant docteur anne de
l'afd à arrêter votre cirque et commencé
à sauver des vies
une vieille tortue sommet de courir
plusieurs lièvres à la fois validées au
plus vite les vaccins de pfizer ou de
moderna sous peine d'appels à la
démission de stéphane le directeur de
l'afd a sous la pression de la maison
blanche c'est finalement le vaccin
finder biotech qui l'emportent le
premier en seulement quelques semaines
ce qui en fait l'autorisation la plus
rapide pour un vaccin de l'histoire de
lagence donald trump lui est déjà dans
les starting blocks pour les premières
injections dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi le président américain a annoncé
le démarrage de la campagne de
vaccination dès dimanche toujours sur
twitter
vous le sommet européen d'hier a permis
aux 27 de s'accorder sur la réduction de
leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'au moins 55 % d'ici à 2030 une annonce
intervenue alors que l'accord de paris
sur le climat célèbre aujourd'hui ses
cinq ans chefs d'état et de gouvernement
se retrouvent lors d'un sommet virtuel
co organisé notamment par paris londres
et l'onu le secrétaire général des
nations unies antonio guterres s appelle
au consensus
c'était donc la faim quant à l'issue de
plusieurs jours de négociations presque
tous les pays du monde ont adopté
l'accord de paris sur les climats
l'objectif contenir le réchauffement
climatique et ses effets néfastes pour
la planète et ses habitants
pour l'atteindre aucune mesure
contraignante mais un engagement à
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la promesse at elle été tenues un
regard défiant sujet est signée mollet
amoudé et florian lambert le dérèglement
climatique et maintenant perceptible par
tous à l'échelle mondiale au cours des
six premiers mois de l'année les
catastrophes climatiques ont poussés à
l'exode près de 10 millions de personnes
mais paris qui s'est positionné en
leader de la lutte pour le climat sur la
scène internationale a bien des
difficultés à réduire ses propres
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le secteur des transports qui est le
plus émetteur en france
elles n'ont pas baissé depuis plus de
dix ans du côté de l'agriculture devenu
le deuxième secteur émetteur en 2019
ces émissions stagne pour ce qui est du
bâtiment il consomme toujours beaucoup
trop d'énergie avec des politiques de
rénovation des logements inefficaces les
cent des ménages face à des factures de
chauffage trop élevé selon
l'observatoire climat énergie en 2019 la
france ait mis 414 millions de tonnes
équivalent co2 en hausse de 2,7 pour
cent par rapport à ses objectifs sur
cette année et nombreux sont ceux qui
pointent du doigt le double discours du
président emmanuel macron qui tantôt se
place en défenseur du climat tantôt en
défenseur de l'énergie nucléaire qui
serait la clé pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique selon lui le
nucléaire c'est de l'emploi et de
l'énergie
je ne suis pas anti nucléaire je lui ai
toujours dit avec beaucoup de force
nous on produit une électricité qui est
parmi elles les plus décarbonés au monde
grâce à quoi
grâce au nucléaire j'ai besoin du
nucléaire
si je le ferme demain qu'est ce que je
fais de son côté l'association
greenpeace ne cache pas sa déception
sous la présidence d manueel macron le
pays de l'accord de paris est
malheureusement en train de perdre son
rang dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique
cette combinaison de défaillances tend
sur les résultats concrets que sur les
moyens mobilisés décridibilise
aujourd'hui la parole des manuels macron
sur l'enjeu climatique et l' influence
française sur la scène internationale
quelque part nous avons déjà perdu le
combat climatique
le président de la république avait
promis de donner sans filtre leurs
propositions législateur or un certain
nombre semble être remis en cause
il faut faire très attention à ce que
les promesses soient tenues
paradoxalement la crise sanitaire aura
eu du bon les émissions de co2 d'origine
fossile ont connu une baisse record de 7
% en 2020 des résultats liés aux mesures
de confinement prises contre l'épidémie
de kobe 19 selon le bilan annuel du
global carbon project finalité de ce
mauvais bilan pour la france
en novembre le conseil d'état a donné
trois mois aux gouvernements pour rendre
compte de ses actions en matière de
lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre la décision de la plus
haute juridiction administrative a été
salué par les défenseurs de
l'environnement
reste à savoir si elle au moins sera
entendu à l'elysée
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve en direct
dans 30 minutes reste avec nous sur rt
france
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelques